les prophètes est passé 13 ans à la
mecque
ils étaient pêchées
et elle était agressée été obligé de s'y
réfugier à la mine et après un an et
demi à peu près à la médine qu'il a eu
la permission d c'est défendre donc est
allégé 4,7 et poussé défendent
premièrement et deuxièmement il faut que
ce soit sous l'égide d'une autorité
légitime et ce qu'on voit maintenant on
n'a pas une autorité légitime qui peut
ordonner les j'ai hâte pour qui tous les
musulmans soient obligés d'aller faire
mais j'ai hâte donc ce n'est pas ça ne
s'applique pas pour le monde tel que ces
messieurs là aymeric sarif jeu dans ce
contexte fait l'atout prises des femmes
la communauté menacée mais à partir de
un demi siècle un siècle plus tard les
musulmans étaient m pap maîtres chez eux
c'est eux qui décident de tout à ce
moment il y avait plus de menace la même
façon donc le jihad ne s'appliquait plus
sa dernière djihad défensif en étant
musulman je suis en guerre comme quand
qui ici est ce que je suis en guerre
contre quelqu'un et quand je lis ces
versets coraniques jeu libre pour moi ça
me concerne absolument pas ce concerne
l'époque les prophètes a interdit
d'étudier des 10 des innocents a
interdit de tuer des civils a dû
interdit de tuer des femmes interdit de
tuer des animaux sont plus capables de
manger ainsi de suite
on voit ce qu'est la terreur qui
séjourne la sem à droite et à gauche et
l'islam
il faut absolument exiger des religieux
et des états aussi qui disent que sont
les états islamiques de déclarer d'une
façon claire et nette que yelle est
versé dans le coran et surtout ses
versets qui font appel à la violence
déclaré
ces versets inopérant